welcome back to the show what an amazing
lighting ceremony for our new
all-american christmas tree it's good to
be back inside the warm studio and mike
rowe is defrosting here with us um i
loved it what do you think this is so
weird man i was walking down the street
looking for a hot dog and i saw the
lights i'm like that what's happening
and i walked over and i got pulled up
now and i'm here and it was it gave you
another dirty job sitting right here on
the five it's a christmas miracle yeah
you're sitting at sadina that's a dirty
job
her language her language is so coarse
yeah it is it's because she's filthy
it's just a filthy person oh all right
let's get this back on track jesse yes
you're a mean one
that is a really deep voice
so what are you talking about mike you
got a big song or something like that
it's like i said man it just couldn't
get stranger this santa claus got a
dirty job thing uh is the uh the number
one downloaded song in the world how'd
that happen
i was on i was on john rich's show the
pursuit and we were talking about music
and then we were talking about dirty
jobs coming back and he said mike rowe
he can't call me mike everything's mike
bro you know he's got a dirty job i said
who he said santa claus
and i said yeah he said we should sing a
song i guess we could and then he walked
in the bathroom during a break and he
came out and he had his iphone in his
hand and he had recorded the chorus to
the song he was my god just
in the bathroom that's an important
detail because as he's playing it for
him where i do my best work i'm
listening to the song but i i can hear
everything else that's going on
i'm like like john rich you got to be
kidding me so two weeks later we
recorded it he called the oak ridge boys
they came in they sang and then he
called his people and now it's the
number one hit well that's the second
number one hit that he's had with
somebody that is true we did do a little
thing and it was for charity and this is
for charity too oh yeah yeah everybody
uh well you
know half goes to me and half goes to
folds of honor which is his foundation
which is terrific so yes we're very nice
people
you know people might see you as like
this hero of the working class with
dirty jobs and then i hear that you were
an opera singer it's almost like either
you're a renaissance man or you're a
schizophrenic i'm not sure why it's got
to be binary you're right well
everything is binary today isn't it no
it's non-binary everything's non-binary
whoever mike wants to non-binary
[Laughter]
that's when it gets weird i'm watching
this at home i always say to myself
when's it going to get weird and it's
usually when you start yeah
just like that how do you go from opera
to a dirty job look it's a it's a super
crooked road but you know once you're in
front of people singing at the top of
your lungs it's only a matter of time
until somebody says you want to crawl
through a sewer for literally hundreds
of dollars and then you say yes and then
you're sitting here with you guys
it's you know the business is strange
did you ever find that hot dog out on
the street or not
not yet but the night is young okay i
can tell you where all the best hot dog
stands are actually in the near vicinity
well i can you know you can smell it
everywhere you walk down the street
you're like
let me ask you what it was like because
well you two were up on the stage you
were able you were up a little higher so
you could see the crowd that was
gathered what was that like honestly so
you've got the firemen behind you you've
got the clergy in front of you you've
got all these familiar faces all around
you got this giant christmas tree behind
you and you guys are doing your thing
but what i said out there i meant last
night around midnight i was just walking
around
and as one does greg yes in midtown
manhattan yes and i'm telling the
officers that you're walking a dog
i know
and i'm and i'm watching the guys
tear down the old rigging
and you should have seen it i mean power
washers welders guys hanging from the
superstructure sparks flying all over
the place and i felt like if john rich
had been there i'd have gone santa claus
got a dirty job but he wasn't so i
didn't
it must be interesting to sing with john
rich because he's got a great voice and
you've got a great voice john is a uh
he's more than a good singer he's a
producer and he really understands his
fans and so this he literally wrote this
song i helped a little bit but it was
mostly him and he did it in about 10
minutes
and then literally an hour later we're
in the booth and then the oak ridge boys
are there and then i just said you know
something i'm just going to get out of
the way and let john do what john does
here we are yeah i got out of the way
when we had the hit song with rich i
think i did the
i clapped maybe a few times and i
screamed but you did a lot of the heavy
lifting well i wrote the song john will
tell you
john will tell you he did but i came
what was the song shut up about politics
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i came up with
everything i have a question for you
though i was thinking about could we
start a new tradition
like a speed tree trimming contest
because that's like that's got to be a
work guinness world 24 hours 24 hours
imagine if you did that at like had some
kind of event every year where people
you pitted groups of people to
to trim the tree the fastest possibly go
wrong nothing nothing like an olympic
event olympic of better than our
olympics that's for sure we don't have
to do it in china
yes look the big story to me and what do
i know about stories but this is i mean
this is the classic when you get lemons
right you make lemonade and to your
point you know you made the lemonade
fast
i often make it fast
you know
it is it doesn't even matter that it's a
holiday does it yeah
it makes it work i think we lit the tree
greg might have lit something else when
we were out there yeah
it's legal
speaking of that can you believe the
dude got released tell me that today yes
amazing where is the guy he's
unsupervised only arson reckless
endangerment and criminal mischief why
not release the government what is
supervised what's the criminal record
yes
let me explain what supervised releases
supervise releases that you're supposed
to call up or or visit someone usually
you call up they don't answer your visit
they're not there so that's supervisor
it's a make-believe world
is this a law that could be changed is
it a city law or state this is a state
law it is a bail law so everybody wants
to know what they can do about the
criminal justice system it's real easy
change the laws so there isn't mandatory
release upon arrest
lock them up
and if they can afford it you let them
out depending upon the seriousness of
the crime and their connections to the
the you know the city this guy's
homeless he's got no connections and
what about allowing judges to have
discretion
and use their judgment yes as to whether
he's a danger yes and you know what the
law was founded on a particularly good
concept and that is
in some places you had someone extremely
poor staying in jail for an inordinate
amount of times because you had some
kind of judge who was a jerk or some d.a
who was a jerk but the truth is all of
us when i was a judge the guy has no
money all right i want to make sure
you're going to return we have pre-trial
release they stay in touch with you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else